so we will shortly bring forward a range  of alternative sites such as disused  holiday Parks former student halls and  surplus military sites we have already  identified locations that could  accommodate 10 000 people are in active  discussions to secure these and More Mr  Sunday flushed her camera then  it's quite serious to take photographs  in the chamber  no no there was a different camera can I  just say if the member knew they'd take  the photograph want to expect them to  lease and expect them to go to the  chamber it's totally unacceptable when  the branch is speaking to disrupt Mr  Black  was it yourself  well I hope it's deleted and speak to  the stone can you go to just have a chat  with the surgeon because it didn't move  that way to me prime minister sorry  about that